I am assistant chief Constable Rachel
Farrell of Dorset police
just after 4 30 PM yesterday we received
a call from colleagues in the ambulance
service requesting assistance on the
beach off Bournemouth Pier
the initial reports received by the
Emergency Services were that a number of
people were in trouble in the sea
a total of 10 people were rescued from
the water
a 17 year old boy from Southampton
and a 12 year old girl from
buckinghamshire
were taken to hospital
where very sadly they later died
my thoughts and those of all the
Emergency Services
are very much with their loved ones at
this horrendous time and we are all
doing all we can to support their
families
the other eight people involved were
treated by ambulance
at the scene
I would sincerely like to spend to thank
members of the public who helped people
in trouble in the water
I'm also very grateful to The Wider
beachgoers who really quickly moved from
the beach and allowed emergency services
to do their work
this incident sparked a multi-agency
response from a range of emergency
services
including the ambulance service Her
Majesty's Coast Guard
r-l-n-l-i the fire service BCP Council
and Dorset police
all these emergency responders came
together to provide a really Swift and
well-coordinated response and did
everything they could to save lives
I thank all of those responders for
their professionalism and their
compassion in the face of this tragedy
an investigation into the circumstances
surrounding this incident has been
launched
and we are working alongside Marine
accident investigation branch and the
maritime Coast Guard agency in
accordance with established protocols
following our initial inquiries a man
aged in his 40s who was on the water at
the time has been arrested on suspicion
of manslaughter
as we have a person in custody you will
know there is only limited information I
can give about the investigation
however to avoid further speculation I
am able to tell you
that it's clear that yesterday a number
of people already in the water got into
difficulty and we are investigating the
circumstances or event that caused that
to happen
early investigation indicates that there
was no physical contact between a vessel
and any of the swimmers at the time of
the incident I can also confirm there is
no suggestion of people jumping from the
pier or jet skis being involved
further information will be released as
the information as the investigation
progresses
as you can imagine we are at the early
stages of our investigation and we would
ask people not to speculate about the
circumstances surrounding the incident
to both protect our inquiries and out of
respect for the victims and their
families we are aware of a number of
videos circulating on social media and
we would urge people to refrain from
doing this
we know the beach was very busy when the
incident occurred I am today
urging anyone who saw what happened or
has any information that may assist to
please come forward
if anyone has relevant phone footage
then they can contact
Dorset police through our major incident
public portal where they can upload the
images and we will share the links on
social media this operation is named
Operation marble
so please share the images with the
police rather than on social media
we'll have our local neighborhood
officers out on patrol over the coming
days alongside colleagues from our local
Council so if you have any information
about the incident or any concerns
please do approach them
I appreciate this incident will have an
impact on all our communities as well as
the very many people who enjoy visiting
Bournemouth and our beautiful beaches we
work closely all year round with our
partner agencies to ensure we have
robust plans in place so people can
enjoy what our county has to offer
safely we are all truly devastated for
two young people have lost their lives
thank you
I'm afraid I cannot answer further
questions about the investigation you
will obviously be aware the
investigation is live we have someone in
custody and I cannot answer further
questions about the arrest investigation
or those circumstances
because we have somebody in custody we
have a live investigation it will be
completely inappropriate for us to
speculate on those details any further
we are trying to share what if
information we can as transparently as
we can to quell um rumors and
speculation what we would ask the public
to do is please bear with us there is an
awful lot of work going on between
partners and police to swiftly
investigate the circumstances gather
evidence and give give the public the
answers we understand that we understand
the need but we need to be able to do
our work with our partners it's complex
investigation and that needs to continue
foreign
as I have said I'm answering no further
questions in respect of the
investigation that would be
inappropriate at this stage okay
so the other eight people were treated
at the scene nobody else was taken to
hospital
[Music]
I'm asked answering no further questions
regarding the investigation can you give
any more information about these
critical injuries the two suffered
I am the the cause of death is a inquiry
for the in coroners we are assisting the
coroner of that inquiry that's at its
early stages that's for a coronal
process so I cannot comment on injuries
or cause of um death at this time
um I can confirm that the children are
not related they're two different
families one from Southampton and one
from buckinghamshire
so so no they they none of the other
eight people had serious injuries um
they they were rescued from the from the
water I'm afraid I I can't say that I
don't have that detail
uh the early indication is it's
different people from different families
who didn't weren't known to each other
who were enjoying the water and those
members of the public that went in to
try and help were also not not related
they were great spirited members of the
public who've tried to us to assist
those in difficulty so this was as you
see today
um groups of people just out enjoying
the water
as I've said I cannot speculate on the
investigation but we are very much
working with expert Partners to try and
understand what happened
um to cause this tragedy
good afternoon I'm Andy Cole I'm the
assistant Chief Fire officer for Dorset
and Wiltshire Farm Rescue service
firstly I'd just like to express the
condolences of Dorset and merch Farm
Rescue to the family and friends of all
of those involved in this tragic
incident
yesterday afternoon Crews from
Westbourne springbourne and pool fire
stations in the Bournemouth Christchurch
and Paul area responded to this
multi-agency incident and supported
other agencies in their attempts to
rescue the casualties involved
thank you
good afternoon I'm councilor Becky Slade
leader of BCP Council
again I want to add our sincere
condolences to the families of the
children who lost their lives and to our
thoughts are with the families and the
young people that are the people that
were in the water it must have been a
really terrifying experience for
everybody
the services worked incredibly well
together our staff on the beach all
rallied round to support the Emergency
Services we're grateful to the public
for clearing the space so quickly and we
are making sure that the staff from the
beach office are getting the support
that they need today and over the
weekend there are additional staff
available for the public on the beach
the beach is busy we are making sure
that there are rnli are very visible and
that our teams are available there to
support people and make sure that they
feel safe on the beach but made's a
really fantastic place to visit and you
know this this incident needs to be
investigated properly and we are
confident with our partners that any
lessons that need to be learned in the
future will will be learned
so there are specific rules uh relating
to the boys out in the in the pit in the
water
um there's no evidence to suggest that
at the moment that any of those walls
have been breached uh we need to
actually uh get the the investigation
done but I I can't give you the specific
rules that's probably an operational
matter to ask our beach teams
as I say it it's a live investigation
and I think our police colleagues have
already explained that we can't comment
further on the details of the
investigation I'm sure that will all
come out in good time
down here
at this point we are thinking about the
families that have lost their children
they came to the beach yesterday for a
great day out and they've gone home
without a child that is our priority at
the moment our staff will do everything
they can to make sure that the beach
remains safe and the teams will be
working hard to make sure that you know
anything that we need to do will be done
at the end of the day
um you know we're always looking at
protocols we work closely with our
colleagues the rnli and others today
isn't for that obviously conversations
will be happening behind the scenes R
and Li are doing an incredible job they
man our beaches you know all through the
season and we pay tribute to their
fantastic work thank you
foreign